you mean ants the movie jeffrey
katzenberg had made in like three months
because he left disney and said they're
putting out a movie about ants let's
make a movie about ants we'll call it
ants but slap a z on it for the kids put
a z on it kids love z's
so tom
tom
tom tom
what are some of the most underrated
animated movies
ever
brian i'm glad you came to me with this
one uh i got the prop for the
only one example came to mind we had a
bunch on the list and uh
i think the problem with a lot of
animated movies is that there's no way
for them to be underrated they tend to
have uh
fan bases that that will that will very
sternly
rate them uh
without going over or under uh
with the following exceptions the lego
batman movie uh from 2017
yes
if you haven't seen it uh it's awesome
liked it more than the actual lego movie
which is a very sweet film uh liked it
more than most batman movies and i'm a
huge batman fan
it is
just brilliant it was written by a
handful of community and uh
uh american dad writers it
paints the batman joker dynamic as
just shy of romantic uh
where
batman isn't ready to settle down and
just have one nemesis
he wants the nemesis around you know he
wants to spread his far and wide and
that really hurts the joker uh it is it
it is just beautifully done
it's brilliant it's one of my all-time
favorite movies uh
always
yeah i saw it in the theaters and i
liked it i remember liking it but i've
been like casually interested in
revisiting it versus the original lego
movie which i loved
um
yeah that's interesting i mean the lego
batman movie is
really good
yes but you say it's better than good
it is it's it's frenetic and uh
constant and i i i love it the cast is
stacked uh the best part of the whole
thing
besides the fact that they had ray finds
playing uh
alfred the butler and that then later on
voldemort shows up and they don't have
him voice him they have to do
it the best part is the part that never
actually got to happen uh we found out
earlier this year that they were going
to make a sequel
uh that never
came around but it was uh michael
waldron uh the the showrunner on on loki
and uh dan harmon wrote the sequel
and uh i didn't hear about this you
didn't hear oh man okay so uh i don't
remember it yeah tell us about it all
that they put out was a uh
so the the problem was that while warner
brothers still has all of the uh the dc
character right uh universal about the
rights to the lego franchise
right i do remember last year i remember
this happening yeah so it yeah it it
killed it was a race dispute that went
across toys and superhero contracts yeah
right
but
they put out the first page of the
sequel
the title of the sequel that dan harmon
michael waldron wrote is lego super
friends based on the lego batman movie
based on the lego movie based on the
lego line of toys which were probably
based on lincoln logs also based on the
dc comics character batman also based on
the dc comics character superman also
based on the dc comics character aquaman
also based on the dc comics characters
the wonder twins also loosely based on
bookie nights based on the cartoon super
friends based on an original idea by dan
harmon and michael waldron
just
incredible off to everybody involved
yeah maybe something happened you never
know yeah
all right nina what about you what's the
most underrated animated movie that you
could think of
so uh tom made a really good point that
i was also kind of going to touch on
which is that i think you go into i went
into this thinking
my original pick was underrated uh and
then i was like spirited away won the
academy award for best animated feature
it is rated correctly because it's a
great movie and i love it um it is not
underrated it's exactly correct it's
exactly right so
yes and so
i kind of was thinking about it some
more and i uh revisited a different
hayamiyazaki movie that i watched a lot
as a kid and that movie is princess
mononoke i don't know if either of you
are either of you familiar with princess
mononoke i am vaguely familiar with both
of those but i will fully admit that i
watched one of them and i don't remember
which one it was it's bad it looks right
once
on a date
and uh and uh yeah that was well they're
different centuries um spirit away came
out in the 2000s
so
if this could fix you at any point in
time um i believe this was back in 1845
when i was oh yeah yeah
yeah you went to got to the movie
theater at a cart pulled by some oxen
yeah yeah they before the movie they
showed uh they showed the train going
through and i got really scared
perfect great ambiance for miyazaki so
princess mononoke is the older of the
two it came out in 1997 uh and what
they've done with pretty much all i
think all but i could be wrong you can
feel free to run a retraction under me
if i am with pretty much all of
miyazaki's movies i think that they have
like pretty much immediately dubbed them
into english and so you have like the
japanese version and then you have the
version with an american cast so for
example in spirited away uh the girl
from the ring i think was the voice of
uh sen the main character i think you're
right yeah uh and
yeah and so princess mononoke was a
movie i watched a lot as a kid which
upon revisiting it i'm like why did my
parents let me watch this because it's
kind of like viscerally gruesome um it's
a movie warning about the dangers of
deforestation and climate change so it's
very weirdly still relevant today but
the american voice cast is ridiculous
it's billy crudup claire danes billy bob
thornton minnie driver jada pinkett
smith you're just like you keep hearing
voices and you're like oh i know exactly
who that is and basically it's about a
um a prince who's the last of his line
named ashitaka who he gets cursed by a
demon after he tries to save
you know himself in battle with it
and he basically has to go kind of into
the center of the forest he meets a girl
named son who it was raised by wolves
and lives amongst them and it's really
just it's a it's a warning tale about
like you know let's not knock down all
the forests and build iron in its place
because we're gonna destroy the earth
but
really good movie really good
performances by the american voice cast
obviously it looks incredible because
it's hayam miyazaki who's a genius um
and i just remember being like wow this
movie still holds up it sent all the
neurons in my brain firing to revisit
some of the scenes because i was like i
haven't watched this since i was a kid
and miyazaki's whole collection is on um
hbo max now so it's very accessible to
anybody who is not familiar with it yeah
it was a big deal because i don't think
they were streaming for years and years
and then finally hbo max got got catalog
rights but good movie still has some
like solid jokes in it um
but like it's a very like there's a lot
of kind of weird demon possession
happening in it and so and the way
demons are represented is like these
gross worm things will just grow out of
like a giant boar and i just remember
being like oh i watched this when i was
eight like a lot and i apparently like
could still sleep at night that's very
weird you know if you could celebrate
the thing
probably so yeah
it's got some weird unsettling imagery
would not recommend it like for a child
under 10 which is ironic considering
when i watched it but really good movie
really holds up and i feel like
especially even in miyazaki's catalog i
think people forget about it a lot
uh compared to
castle or spirited away right my
neighbor totoro so yeah go watch this
movie on hbo max it's really good yeah
i had a blast revisiting it yeah hmm
interesting and that's good to know that
they're on hbo max now i have something
something to check out yeah um
some of the movies on this list on
looper.com i have actually seen in
theaters some of them i don't remember
much about
but i would probably argue that they're
underrated titan ae did either of you
see that one unfamiliar
i saw that when it came out in theaters
that's a matt damon joint i think they
animated him with the the mushroom cut
did that run at the beginning of it on
that damon joint did he is he ripping
off basically entirely now yeah
i think that that's the no that's
definitely the one where
if you can look it up on youtube you
know you can you can rent movies on
youtube uh
it looks like they found the worst fan
art like
on the internet to use as the poster
like it doesn't look like dreamworks
could have ex or whoever made the movie
it can't be like
the official poster for this thing it's
just this nightmare oh yeah look at that
yeah
that's real bad
yeah i'm going to share that in our chat
you see
it looks like ms paint 201
this is my final project
it's so bad
oh god much worse than the movie would
would make this looks like it was pretty
good it looks like it wouldn't have made
the cut for a carmen san diego cd-rom
game
many of which i played
and they had terrible graphics
you know
tight-knit is like a space adventure
it's fun it's got nathan lane as like a
caddy mean alien which is
nice
i remember it was pretty good and that
it just also kind of faded away another
movie kind of in a similar vein treasure
planet uh one of the one of the
i think atlantis and treasure planet are
both kind of on the two sides of the
same coin they're big budget disney
animated adventures
geared towards young men you know
there's not so much princesses in it um
i remember watching atlantis at least
yeah a couple times
yeah that was like i probably had that
one
yeah atlantis yeah i remember reading an
article about it not too long ago on i
think it was polygon
um and it goes into detail about how um
the guy who created hellboy mike
mignolet
yeah
uh he did a bunch of the the designs for
that movie and so like one of the
reasons why they have such a specific
look is that they're basically
dignifying mike mignola's weird creepy
artwork
um
treasure planet another treasure island
in space sure why not i remember it
being pretty good and then i also don't
remember anything else about it i think
david hyde pierce plays like a fop in it
like he's just a floppish alien
prince of egypt
i remember enjoying a bunch uh because i
am a jewish person and it tells the
story of passover
[Laughter]
so so that's something that x-men energy
though
yeah with wild songs and excitement and
drama and sandra bullock and jeff
goldblum and val kilmer
um so that's important
road to eldorado is on here i started
that because i read that it was
apparently very good but i i watched
that movie all the time i remember it
very well super duper funny and good it
was it was pretty funny i remember like
that was on in the house a lot when i
was a young and a youth
kevin klein and who else
is that right oh that's yeah
sir
sir
yeah there's some good memes from that
movie
um that are floating around but the two
that i'm going to talk about
specifically are the ones that i really
really do love now one of them that's on
this list of underrated and it's
probably underrated because if you ask
the average person whether or not
they've seen this movie they'll probably
be like no what's that and if you ask
any like fan of animation or animated
movies they'll be like yes that's an
amazing movie why are you even asking me
about it and it's the iron giant yeah
yeah right this is a movie that flopped
when it came out and it just holds up
because it'll break your heart
it's it's one of the few movies that can
reliably
get me very emotional by the end
oh man what am i that was that was a
brad bird joint right if we're gonna
yeah but it wasn't that did that kind of
kick-start you know him as a powerhouse
and animation because then he went on to
do stuff like incredibles and
ratatouille and some of the greatest
modern it was before it was obviously
before those but yeah i mean i would
imagine that put them on the map for
animators in general i think for the
people who knew what was what they were
like oh this movie by this guy brad bird
you know it may not have done very well
but we need to get him making movies for
us and like do a good marketing budget
and you know um but yeah so if if anyone
watching this hasn't seen the iron giant
i i strongly suggest that you watch it
as soon as possible it's about basically
takes place during the cold war in
america 1950's america it's got this
young kid and a single mom and the kid
is just lonely and he's weird and he
needs a friend and then
a giant killer robot from space
lands on earth and he becomes friends
with it because it's lost its memory and
it kind of grows and becomes this story
about like what makes us who we are what
makes us human you know
do you have to be a a human to be a
human or
you know if you're a human does that
automatically mean you lose your
humanity and it's just this really great
fable that
it's pretty much perfect from start to
finish so again fans of animation
fans of animation know
this movie is
incredible so it's not underrated in
that regard it's got great reviews
it bombed when it came out though
and
if you've never seen it you might not
know what's so special about it so i
strongly urge you to see that one
it's also the mark of uh quickly it's
the mark of uh vin diesel's first voice
role as a gentle giant he would later
then play groot because he voices
the giants
which i forgot about until just now then
i looked it up gentlest giant of all
dominic toretto
right he learned in iron the importance
of family that's his last line as he
flies up
into the sky with the new yeah
he goes fast
furious
family
is this when he was driving a car into
space in f9 which
i have not seen yet but i know what
happens
yeah he quotes the iron giant
yeah
comes full circle
the other movie on this list that i
really want to talk about that i
absolutely adore that i do think is
underrated because i don't think a lot
of people have seen it as batman mask of
the phantasm i know you're gonna say
that now tom really you mentioned lego
batman as being one of your favorite
batman movies i contend batman mask of
the phantasm is way better
whoa fascinating and more underrated
it's it's a very pretty movie uh
by the way mike mignolet don't know if
you know this the guy that made hellboy
and also atlantis just tying the whole
thing together also the guy that uh
redesigned mr freeze for the batman the
animated series
yep uh that sounds changed him from like
a weird old bald man in a fishbowl hat
into this like creepy anyway batman mask
of the fantastic i remember when that
came out and uh even as a child i was
like well this
this this is a tv show why is this going
to the movie theater and i feel like
that's kind of what most audiences
thought right like the people who saw it
thought that it was great but it was
originally being made for release on
video but then basically
i think it might have been to fill a
hole in the schedule or maybe they just
saw how it was shaping up they elevated
it to a full theatrical release
and
it really holds up it's got
it's got an amazing story it's got great
great voice acting great set pieces
there's an amazing fight with the joker
and batman and the phantasm at the end
that is just like
i'll put it up against any other i'll
put this movie up against any other
batman movie until christopher nolan put
out um batman begins and especially dark
knight this was the best batman
um i think that lego batman is probably
like do you like adam west batman do you
like silly batman comic book stuff this
is your batman move it's definitely like
it's it's very much divorced from the
comics and the original story the
grimness and
really the characters
yeah mask of the phantasm delivers on
basically the promise that the animated
series had which was you know this
serious more dramatic pulpy
uh adventure of batman
uh and this this one delivers on it
because there's
it's not that violence makes things good
but when you're dealing with a story
that involves criminals and killers and
gangsters and psychotic clowns any guy
who punches them until they stop yeah
violence kind of helps so there's like
there's this there's this villain out
there phantasm who's basically dressed
like the grim reaper out there bumping
off mobsters and batman is trying to
solve the crime trying to solve the
mystery of who who the phantasm is and
how to stop it you get you get some
insight into this world's uh joker but
before he became the joker it's the only
piece of
media in this animated universe that
goes into that and it's just like this
little tiny bit and it's just
ah perfect it's so good it's one of my
favorites um so yeah again if you've
never seen it can't recommend it enough
i know you're gonna pick that and not
ants with a z
it sucks
it does suck
it's not a good movie sorry
starring jennifer lopez christopher
walken and woody allen
and sylvester stallone oh is he in that
too you mean ants the movie jeffrey
katzenberg had made in like three months
because he left disney and said they're
putting out a movie about ants let's
make a movie about ants we'll call it
ants but slap a z on it for the kids put
a z on it kids love z's
i'm sorry list
ants ants is bad ants is a bad movie i'm
gonna say no to ants on that one i'm
trying to think if there's any other
movies i would add to this you know what
i'm going to add to this to this list
before we go hit me um i mentioned
prince of egypt that i enjoy as a jewish
person because it tells the story of
passover and i like representation um
but to go on the complete opposite end
of the spectrum i really like the movie
arthur christmas
i didn't know where you were going with
that okay it's a christmas movie it's
delightful i think it's wonderful
uh james mcavoy i pretty sure plays
the titular arthur christmas
articular role yeah it's got um
hugh laurie as his big brother
i don't remember his first name probably
like rory christmas or something
and so basically the the the way that
this world
the way that this world treats santa
claus is that it's a it's a thing you
pass from generation to generation so
arthur
roberts yeah yeah exactly so
arthur is this is the son of santa claus
and he he just loves christmas but he's
kind of a klutz but he ends up he ends
up saving christmas at the end spoilers
it's a really good animated movie that's
probably underrated i don't think a lot
of people have seen it
i got it on dvd as a gift a year ago and
i remember liking anastasia a lot as a
kid with meg ryan in the lead role and
which luckily did not end the way that
anastasia's real story ended it would
start the way that anastasia's
a lot of people really like my my sister
loved that movie growing up i uh though
it's one of those ones and i feel like
this happens
my favorite animated movie starring meg
ryan john cusack and kelsey grammer
go to the go-to names for children's
entertainment yeah great voice acting
again people the kids loved
you sleepless in seattle
[Laughter]
cast tom hanks thanks for watching
please hit like and subscribe
see you later